hi welcome to today's live broadcast
personalized medicine using integrative
omics and big data to analyze complex
disease and managed health I'm Bruce
Goldman of the Stanford University
School of Medicine's office of
communication and i'll be your moderate
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by Stanford University for
more information please visit
med.stanford.edu that's m.ed
stanford.edu we've got a few important
announcements before we begin this
website is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
about the event you can submit questions
by typing them in the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking on the green Q&A
button on the lower left of your
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can also you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would like now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Michael
Snyder he is the Stanford a Sherman
professor and chair of genetics at the
stanford university school of medicine
and he's the director of the center of
genomics and personalized medicine dr.
Schneider received his PhD at Caltech
and carried out postdoctoral training at
Stanford University he was at Yale
University for many years before
returning to Stanford in 2009 to lead
the genetics department he's a leader in
the field of functional genomics and
proteomics and one of the major
participants of the encode project his
laboratory was the first to perform a
large-scale in functional genomics
project in
organism and has developed many
technologies and genomics and proteomics
these technologies have provided
fundamental insights into our
understanding of the human genome how it
is regulated how it evolved and how we
are different from one another dr.
Snyder has also combined different
state-of-the-art omics technologies to
perform the first longitudinal detailed
integrative personal omics profile of a
single person and used this to assess
disease risk and monitor disease states
for personalized medicine he is a
co-founder of a number of biotechnology
companies I'm now going to turn it over
to dr. Schneider for his presentation
thanks Bruce pleasure to be here so
today I do want to tell you about our
approaches using combining different
omics technologies to try and tackle
complex diseases and I really want to
tell you two stories one is longitudinal
profiling of people to be able to better
understand health and disease states
this is an update of a story many of you
may have heard about actually profiling
me and then the second part of the
presentation will actually deal with
some of our new work trying to dissect
autism which is complex but
ever-increasing disease that's affecting
the human population so just put this in
perspective I think many of you realize
this is an area that's become extremely
high interest lately with the recent
announcement from President Obama about
a personalized or precision medicine
initiative the hope is to be able to
better manage people's health with
precise precise care and treatment and
what frames they're thinking a lot is
really the slide here which is your
health it's a complex state but it's
something where you toggle between
healthy periods and disease period so if
you look at the right part of the slide
a lot of the time we're healthy but with
various perturbations we can acquire
disease and really there's many factors
that contribute to this at your DNA your
genome your collection of all your bases
but it's also all the things you're
exposed to so the food you eat the
pathogens you might be exposed to
various life stresses
your exercise even your age all these
things contribute to your health and one
of the goals of our lab and many other
labs this is trying to understand us in
quantitative terms that is if you're
born with a certain DNA sequence if
you're exposed to certain environmental
cues or maybe certain viruses it will
actually lead to a certain health
outcome for some people you may remain
healthy and others you may actually
become ill and again the goal is to
understand this in probabilistic terms
now this idea isn't new it's been around
a long long time and there's even a
popular movie about this I like to show
this because I think many of you are
probably listening have actually seen
this movie already it's got a gut movie
that's now over 20 years old but many of
the facts in there I think they're still
relevant today and they actually called
them facts and some I just have now
become facts they weren't back when the
movie was made but anyway the idea is
that you you with a certain DNA sequence
and a certain exposure might predict
health outcomes now I think as many of
you know the first part of the equation
that the genome is now very solvable
that is the cost of genome sequencing
has dropped dramatically starting from
only 10 years ago where it costs
something on the order of about a
billion dollars originally the sequence
of human genome these days you can
actually get a human genome sequence for
twelve hundred dollars or sorry fourteen
hundred dollars that's not the
interpretation that's just a sequencing
costs but the point is that it's
actually relatively inexpensive to get
the genome sequence mind you the
interpretation still is expensive it
costs something on the order of about
fifteen thousand dollars to interpret
human genome at least the way we do it
nonetheless because the cost of genome
sequencing is dropping a lot genome
genomics and Jim sequencing is having
huge impact in medicine and human health
this slide just illustrates some of the
examples these are areas that we and
many other people participate in genome
sequencing is having huge impact on
treating cancer these days it's very
common to either get your whole genome
or targeted regions of your genome
sequence if you have cancer the goal
there is to try and find mutations that
have acquired when cancer is arisen and
be able from that information be able to
select treatments where there might be a
genetic alteration and there's a drug
that can basically treat a particular
cancer based on that genetic change
likewise solving undiagnosed or mystery
diseases is becoming more commonplace
using genome sequencing you may not know
but something on the order of about 0.4%
of children are born each year with the
serious health defect and people are now
turning to genome sequencing to try and
solve those most about half the time
those health defects can't be solved in
genome sequencing is being used to try
and solve those and that works in about
a quarter of the time so 25 percent of
the time children with serious diseases
actually get there their case solved if
you will not necessarily treated but at
least the diagnosis solved by actually
sequencing the genome lastly in the area
prenatal diagnostic genome sequencing is
also becoming common mostly for tests
for aneuploidies that is chromosome
abnormalities specifically chromosome 21
18 and 13 there's a prenatal test that
you can do and it's not by doing
amniocentesis it's actually by pulling
DNA out of the pregnant mother and
actually sequencing the fetal DNA to be
able to detect these chromosome
abnormalities and in fact it's possible
to actually sequence an entire child's
genome from DNA that's floating around
in the mother's blood so we're in a
revolution where genome sequencing is
actually having a huge impact for
treating disease and actually for trying
to catch disease early at least in the
case of prenatal diagnostic but in one
area that's still very very
controversial is the part at the bottom
of the slide if you're a healthy person
can genome sequencing be beneficial to
you and if so what might you learn from
a genome sequence and how to use is to
help manage your health now specifically
this problem is addressed on this slide
here the idea is that your genome
sequence together with other sorts of
information for example your family
history and information you might get
from a routine medical exam your blood
pressure other things you'll try and
combine this information to be able to
better predict disease risks diagnose
disease
monitor disease states leaves based on
pharmacogenomic profiles and potentially
treat disease all bass all using your
genetic information helped guide you and
as I say you wouldn't just do the genome
sequence you'd bring in other sorts of
information and one step further that we
decide to take those not only just bring
in the limited amount of information you
might get from a medical test but it's
bringing lots and lots of other kind of
information as well so specifically we
can actually bring in information where
we can measure many many more molecules
our entire transcript them if you will
that means all our RNAs proteomes all
the proteins metabolomic all your
metabolites so specifically we try and
actually not only measure your DNA but
all these other arms as well and so I
moved the Stanford about six years ago
and at that time we decide to set up
what we call personal amex profiling and
the idea is that in addition to your
genome so the thing at the top of the
slide you could also get all these other
arms measured as well your epigenome and
for us that means DNA methylation I'll
tell you a little bit about that later
transcript them again meaning all your
RNA proteome which is really your
proteins and for this we're most mostly
measuring out of your peripheral blood
monocytes else i should say most of
these assays are done out of bodily
fluids so blood and your immune cells
are called your peripheral with blood
monocytes cells we actually purify to
measure your transcriptome also your
protium your proteome we also measure
out of your your flute blood fluid your
plasma if you will and also out of your
serum the per diem as we measure it uses
mass spectrometry and it captures now
about the top two-thirds of your
proteins but it does miss some of the
rare and important proteins cytokines of
some of those important proteins so we
actually have a high throughput asset
for following those we also have been
optimizing the tabba lummox it's a very
under explored area and basically we've
developed technologies now to be able to
follow about 20,000 metabolites features
if you will using mass spectrometry from
both plasma and urine so we can get very
detailed analysis of people's
metabolites although I should point out
we only
no what about fifteen hundred of those
metabolites are we also follow the
antibodies you make against yourself and
the action against all viral proteins we
have chips the basic cover the whole
human proteome and also cover the whole
common human by room about 120 human
viruses are displayed on that chip and
lastly most recently we've added on the
human microbiome we do five different
micro biomes your stool you're in nasal
tongue and skin so we can follow a lot
of the microbes living in and on you and
I'll have more to say about that later
as well and together these make up your
personal omics profile so before we had
the epigenome and the microbiome we were
studying about roughly 40,000 molecules
when we first set this up and now by
actually improving the technology and
studying the microbiome a a better auto
antibody detection and the epigenome we
literally make billions of measurements
every time we sample someone okay so
initially we rolled out the study many
of you may know by studying me we've
actually been profiling me for over five
years now so actually this month pretty
soon I'll hit my 60 second month if you
will where I've been profiling myself
and I've taken over 100 samples during
this time the microbiome and the the DNA
methyl em well DNA methylin will cover
everything you'll hear but the
microbiome has just been added on the
last two and a half three years or so so
basically during this time as you can
probably see from the slide I've had a
number of viral infections and in fact
I've had seven in total one of them's
not shown they're all common colds for a
rhinovirus infection shown a red to red
no virus infections and the third of the
last one is respiratory syncytial virus
infection that's in green and basically
all these again are common cold some of
them are more severe than others and RSV
is common in kids not very common in
adults when adults do get that they do
get pretty sick which was true for me
and the way the study is designed we
actually sample people fairly
infrequently so every two to three
months when they're healthy and then
much more frequently went on to go one
of these disease states if you will so
every time I get a viral infection we
do take a number of samples and for
example for the RSV infection we took my
blood when i first got congested that
one day later two days two days after
that three days after that four days and
so on so we do dense profiling again
when sick and then every two to three
months when healthy and at times where
there might be something interesting
going on for example before and after
Australia things like that so again then
sampling during disease states every two
to three months when healthy now I'm
going to skip over the first part go
through it fairly quickly because I'd
like to tell you about some of the newer
things we've done but basically started
by sequencing my genome which predicted
as risk for a number of different things
the up here is one sort of analysis we
do with this this is analyzing my risk
for complex diseases this is called a
risk a gram and this predicts my chances
of getting a disease and you can do this
for hundreds of diseases i'm just
showing the top of this but on the right
are actually the various diseases that
we analyze and over over my lifetime I
have a hundred percent chance if you get
to that bar or a 0% chance them on the
left side and the triangle is my
starting point and the orange bar is my
increased chance based on my genome
sequence and blue bars my decreased
chance again also on my genome sequence
for getting any of those diseases and
this basically sums over a number of
your risk alleles so try and predict
your disease it's basically about 23 me
used to do and so this is my risk a gram
and mine match my family history or what
I knew about it and my health very well
so for example that one of those bottom
stars you'll see at a low risk for for
obesity nobody in my family has ever
been overweight a high risk for coronary
artery disease that I knew already since
everyone on my father's side has died of
some sort of heart problem and then
you'll see actually lipid miss
regulation at the top and
hypertriglyceridemia to statins and so
on but there were some surprises one of
which is on a high risk for basal cell
carcinoma and in fact I learned later
that in fact
family members have had that in my
family and so I like to say actually
although we didn't know it initially we
this really got revealed from a genome
sequence and I do think your genome
sequence is a better record of your
family history than your family is
because you can actually follow this
information much better from your genome
it doesn't transfer very well in your
family the other thing you'll notice
where that big bar is is high risk for
type 2 diabetes i went from something
like a twenty-six percent chance of
forty seven percent chance of getting
type 2 diabetes in my lifetime and that
was a surprise to me i was not aware of
that for my family history but we had
been following remember all my
metabolites and these other molecules
and we had also been doing medical tests
to follow glucose and other things as
well and one and because we were
following glucose we could actually in
fact monitor this and it so happens that
initially my glucose levels were running
fine but remarkably about nine months
into the study in fact they shot my
glucose shot through the roof that was
really a surprise to me and the other
md's we were working with we didn't
necessarily expect that and initially we
picked it up at that inflection point
which is a dot just before the 6.2 a
week later we did the measurement at
that 6.4 dot my glucose had actually
gotten almost 150 my hemoglobin a1c
which is a measure for steady state
glucose arisen to 6.4 that's actually
borderline diabetic it's arbitrary but
type 2 diabetics are classified as being
diabetic at 6.5 or higher and then five
weeks later we measure it again and my
glucose was even higher 150 and the
hemoglobin a1c was six point seven I was
classified as diabetic so that was four
years ago as April 11 2011 I remember
that because up until that point I've
been eating a lot of sugars I'd bike
some but not all that much and on that
date when I got the second type second
measurement if you will high hemoglobin
a1c I basically went cold turkey and I
cut out all suites I've had only one bit
bite of wedding cake in the last four
years and I don't have sodas or anything
like that I doubled my biking and I
started running and it didn't happen
right away it took about six months to
bring my glucose down to that baseline
level again that you see on the right
but so it took a long time but I
gradually did get it under control so
this made a big deal at the time because
it's the first time someone user genome
to predict their risk for the disease
and in fact got that disease and in my
case the informations are useful I could
manage my disease just by changing my
lifestyle my food and my exercise and it
worked out pretty well it's also quite
intriguing if you'll notice when this
happened it came right after this nasty
respiratory syncytial virus infection
and so our hypothesis is that my genome
has me predisposed for type 2 diabetes
and then in conjunction with this viral
infection or the stress response
associated with it that's what really
triggered the disease that's the
hypothesis and we haven't proven this
but it is an amazing correlation if
you'll see there and it can tell you
lots of other people it turns out have
had a similar experience so this is all
anecdotal it's not real science but
plenty of people have emailed me after
we publish this thing they had a very
similar experience either for them or a
family member we're after viral
infection they actually lost glucose
regulation so this is something we're
now testing as we go further a lot of
people say well make that's great you
know that happened but you know maybe it
really would have gone away on its own
maybe this whole thing is just a fluke
well we accidentally did a blind
experiment because the person who
started the study we reach n went off
looking for jobs and as we expanded
you'll see in a minute to increase the
number of people in our study it so
happens another person took over we were
very busy lots of samples came in and
nobody was really looking at the data
and so it turns out i had stopped
running but and it turns out after that
first bout so you'll if you see on the
left where there's that big spike of
glucose that's the same spike i showed
you before blue is glucose read his
hemoglobin a1c they're both measures for
high sugar if you will so I had gotten
it under control but about a year and a
half later that I had stopped running
and once you know up my sure levels
skyrocket it again
and we hadn't really noticed this
because we were just collecting samples
nobody's looking at the data but
amazingly it sort of that highest second
bump somebody looked at at that time so
about ten months to a year later someone
looked at the data and some Mike you
realize your hemoglobin a1c seven point
0 again and I your diabetic so I'd once
I discovered that I started running I've
gotten it lower I've got my hemoglobin
a1c down to five point seven but I'm
that's probably about as low as I seem
to be able to go with my current
exercise so the bottom line out of
wholeness is that i do think i have a
metabolic disorder it's pretty clear
pretty clear it's apparent and that you
know my shirt who runs high and if I
don't do something it's it's not high
levels that really are very healthy for
me so I really have to manage this
carefully and it's not just me my
brothers and sisters all have high
hemoglobin a1c two and they're all
either as thin as me or a thinner so
again no question we have a metabolic
disorder running in our family and this
all got revealed starting with my genome
sequence now remember we're also doing
all these other homes as well excuse me
the transcriptome party I metabolomic in
40,000 measurements now many more and we
actually can follow all the changes in
my molecular profile during these
interesting times during viral
infections during the time I got type 2
diabetes now drawing some other
interesting times I'll tell you about
and basically you can see your pathways
change at a level no one's ever been
able to do before it's like getting an
IMAX movie but what's happening when you
go through one of these disease states
and return to healthy and as compared to
what I would call today today's really
fuzzy radio at bats we're really stumble
around the way we do medicine if you ask
me so just as one example at the top
panel there in green or all the
molecules that went down during the time
I got type 2 diabetes and red are the
ones that went up and if they looked at
the pathway so I went down it turns out
my insulin biosynthetic pathway dropped
during this time and in fact my insulin
levels have never
excuse me been the same on average as
they were at the beginning of the study
okay so I do make less and less insulin
and there are other interesting pathways
to change some of these you are able to
see by RNA some you're able to see by
proteins but some you only see by
getting the combined information so the
combined information is much much better
than anyone I'm alone now since these
first studies we've actually expanded it
quite a bit we've added on the DNA
methyl m so we've now analyzed over 40
of my time points we're seeing some very
interesting changes there I think this
is going to be incredibly fascinating
why are we doing this way your methyl um
is very interesting it's affected by if
you will your environmental influences
so your DNA methylation pattern it's
been shown to be affected by nutrition
by lifestyle factors such as exercise
even aging effects your DNA methylation
in fact you can tell someone's age by
the the specific modifications on 353
sites this is worked for by Robert
Horvath who actually discovered this and
basically it works I can tell you that
that for me from my DNA methylation
pattern we've done whole genome
bisulfite methylation and it turns out
my age my methylation age is within a
year of my real age it really picked it
out quite nicely of course I wanted to
have the age of a 25 year old but it
didn't really work out that way it
really does match quite well so again we
don't know exactly how this works how
the DNA methylation correlates with age
and and nutrition and those sorts of
things but we have been mapping out my
methylation patterns is across time and
there are some interesting changes just
one interesting story out of all this is
that we've looked for interesting
examples where I might have disease
genes where one copy if you will
remember if two copies of our genes one
from our mom one from our dad but one of
the copies might be mutated by genetic
mutation the other might be turned off
by DNA methylation which is known to
silence jeans and this is just one
example here where this gene kc j kc NJ
18 and actually we think is inactivated
by two different methods
my father's copy has damaging mutations
my mother's copy actually is methylated
and we have I have five examples like
this in the genome and at least for two
of them the gene doesn't get expressed
the one that's methylated so we really
think they are shut off and so I will
argue in the future you don't want to
just get your your genome done you're
probably going to want to get your DNA
methylation pattern determined as well
because they think this is going to give
you some sense of both the inherited
alleles that appear as well as any
environmental influences that might be
impacting you they may show up in your
DNA methylation pattern so this is one
way in which we hope to be able to
capture the expose them the other sort
of information we're now collecting
these your microbiome so basically you
probably know that there are 10 times as
many cells in and on you that aren't you
than are you that is to say we have 10
trillion human cells but a hundred
trillion bacteria and this is essential
for us the bacteria in your gut helps
you digest the food that you eat makes
essential vitamins that we all need and
without we would die b12 one of many
examples and these days the microbiome
has been implicated and probably every
disease you can imagine and I've just
listed a few here inflammatory bowel
disease including things like crowns and
ulcerative colitis diabetes of obesity
myocardial infarction in these cases
there probably is good good evidence
that the microbiome does influence these
disease states and in fact you may have
heard about fecal transplants then use
to help correct some of the colitis and
inflammatory bowel problems that people
have that's really a microbiome transfer
mind you the microbiome has probably
been implicated in every disease in most
cases it's not really clear what's cause
and effect and that needs to be sorted
out but in these cases it seems likely
there is a direct association so we've
actually started looking at this now
I'll tell you a story here one little
later and basically we did when we
launched this we decide to pick one very
interesting time point I had I had a
rhinovirus infection the one circle
there
was quite interesting the beginning of
it was a rider virus infection but nine
days later I got a second fever and we
took on kites and swabs but couldn't
figure out what it was so when we
started analyzing the microbiome mind
you my nasal got tongue skin and urine
microbiome we thought this would be an
interesting time to look at to begin
with and so we started by looking at my
nasal microbiome where one might think
the infection would reside and basically
we did both whole genome shotgun
sequencing and 16s and this is just the
top of my profile there are many many
abundant species here and I'm just
showing you the most interesting ones at
the top to make the presentation simple
but basically on the left column is when
I was healthy the second column is when
actually had this mysterious infection
two days later is the recovery period
two and a half days later as the next
recovery phase and then I'm back to
healthy and the last column and one
bacterium that circled there is
streptococcus pneumoniae actually
correlates very well with when I'm sick
so the odds are i had a streptococcus
infection during this mysterious
infected time so the bottom line is we
were able to figure out what this
infection was and mind you this is
probably the world's most expensive way
to have done this to figure it out i had
a strep infection but nonetheless it was
a great as proof of principle we what
was interesting about this studies we
not only looked at my nasal microbiome
we looked at my stool microbiome and
that's shown here shown in a different
way but on the left are my healthy stool
samples a very similar two parts of a
stool on the right is when i returned to
healthy and in general they're not
identical but they're pretty similar but
you'll notice when i got the fever this
mysterious infection the pie chart
shifts a lot so the bacteria i have
actually shift quite a bit and then a
recovery period that you start shifting
back towards healthy and the bottom line
out of all this is that when you get one
of these infections it doesn't just
affect the the area that's a directly
affect it affects your whole body so I'm
not saying that the BET the strep
infection directly caused my stool
microbiome of change it could be in
could be the food a could be you know
the mucosal drip that goes into your gut
could all be indirect but point out of
all this is it's a systems wide change
to really understand what's going on in
your health I think we need all these
detailed kinds of measurements to be
able to see again across your entire
body in a systems wide fashion what's
really going what's going on and that's
really one of the goals of this let's
get you get it system-wide analysis of a
person when they're sick we're now
adding on other kinds of information
this is just some of the information
here there now you may know devices that
can measure many different physiological
parameters so I have some of these some
of these are free like the moves app on
the top left you can download that onto
your smartphone it measures all your
steps you're biking you're running keeps
track it turns out it's pretty accurate
we think I have a basis watch which also
measures heart rate sleep stress
responses we think sleep is really
important measures all the activities as
well and those measures skin temperature
and you can even measure electric
cardiogram right on your iPhone on the
top left is I can my electric car
cardiogram measure off your particular
application that I was able to get on my
iPhone and so we make actually many many
different measurements and so bottom
line is we can we can not only get
detailed molecular measurements but we
can also get a lot of physiological
measurements again to get a more
complete picture of what's going on with
a person so we're now expanding this out
as you might imagine and other people
and this is just this slide just shows
some of the people some of the
sequencing weaves studies we've done so
we've sequence quite a few different
healthy people and this is again to some
of the studies and the top one is one we
do with you and Ashley and others where
we actually sequence a family of four
discovered the father had a factor five
blood clotting mutation and it turns out
the daughter had inherited that forty
the teenage daughter why is this
relevant wild actually affect might
affect her birth control decisions
because some of the birth control
options actually do need to increase
clotting and so she might think
about other options knowing that she's
at higher risk for blood clots with this
factor 5 mutation we've also recently
sequenced a set of 12 healthy people one
woman had out of the 12 I in fact had a
bracket mutation and what was remarkable
she did not have a family history of
breast ovarian camps it's a bracket
mutation you may know it is associated
with high incidence of breast and
ovarian cancer and this individual had
this but do not of a family history as a
woman and based on this information she
actually opted for surgery a la Angelina
Jolie so she basically decided to use
their genome information to make a very
important decision and I'm not saying
everyone who gets a black mutation
should in fact have bresser or their
breasts or ovaries removed but I think
it's very important information to have
and so the point out of all this is you
can learn things from your genome that
you wouldn't necessarily have and on
average i'd say we with when we sequence
a person's genome it leads to about
three or so follow-up tests that people
often do which aren't necessarily all
that expensive on average it's about
eight hundred dollars worth of tests for
every person we sequence so this is a
it's a reasonable number but it's not
extraordinarily expensive so going
around sequencing people isn't going to
lead to millions of dollars of follow-up
tests necessarily which is one of the
major criticisms of this area the other
thing that's going on is we've now
enlarge their study and we're following
70 it's gradually rolling to a hundred
pre-diabetics some people with elevated
glucose along with some healthy controls
we're following them exactly like me
that is to say we sample them every few
months when they're healthy and then a
very dense sampling when they get a
viral infection and quite a few have now
actually had a viral infection or a
vaccination so we profile them densely
during this period a lot of these
individuals are also undergoing some
interesting perturbation studies this is
just one example here so we have about
35 which 20 have completed a study to
actually which
they undergo what we call overfeeding
where they actually go on a high cleric
diet for basically 30 days they eat an
extra thousand calories a day for 30
days they gained seven pounds on average
and then they basically go on a low
caloric diet and come back to baseline
that takes about 60 days so we sample
them at the beginning after they gain
weight after they return to baseline and
throughout the study and really the goal
of this is to see what kinds of changes
occur when people have these kinds of
weight gains and weight losses and some
of the individuals we have they're all
matched for weight but some are insulin
sensitive and some are insulin resistant
which is a precursor for type 2 diabetes
so even before we start the weight gain
part where they're very interesting
differences and we can tell you that the
insulin sensitive and insulin resistant
people do not look the same at all even
other match for bodyweight some the
insulin resistant folks turns out they
have increased oxidative phosphorylation
and other changes relative to the
insulin sensitive one so the point is
they're biochemically different from the
insulin sensitive ones and there's other
interesting changes as well we can pick
this up just from the are any data we
also see very interesting metabolomic
profiles of these folks as well so the
point is that there there are very
fundamental differences between these
individuals and we're trying to
understand where that's coming from it
might even be coming from this sat in
some cases from their DNA the ultimate
goal out of all the so i should say when
they go through weight changes in weight
losses as you might imagine they see
with dramatic changes both in their RNA
their metabolites and even their
microbiome when they gain weight and
also when they lose weight and the
insulin sensitive or resistant folks are
actually quite a bit different we're
also running people through interesting
dietary perturbations as well the
ultimate goal out of all this is a
really understand what happens to people
at an individual level when they undergo
certain perturbations and on this slide
of just showing the perturbation being
you know a giant hamburger so that if
you know two different people ate the
same hamburger some cases they say
same another key it's the bottom on in
some cases they may gain weight like the
top one and we'd like to understand why
that is and I've shown it here for a
hamburger but the same is true for viral
infection stress response anything you
can imagine so really the goals are
trying to understand for example for me
why is it I got type 2 diabetes after
this RSV infection and other people
don't presumably there are plenty of
people running around to get RSV
infections you don't have their sugar go
out of control so we'd like to try and
pin that down better and the ultimate
goal again is understand individuals and
how they react to certain environments
we don't want it we want under seen it
globally but we also want to understand
it really at the personal level so at
the end of the day you can manage your
health based on the sort of information
this is what I see is the future for
this field which is this is what i like
to call mike snyder's future where I
envision a world where you get your
genome sequence before birth other sorts
of information will be measured maybe
not as detailed as what we're doing
probably certainly won't be that quite
that detailed but a lot of this will be
able to be measured through home sensors
in fact I have a sensor on me right now
it's measuring glucose continuously a
lot of those will actually feed into
your iPhone where you ought be measuring
other activity measurements like your
steps and biking and things like this
and all this information will be
collected their relayed back to you to
help you be able to better manage your
health that's the world I see in the
future and so this is a world I don't
think it's going to be all that far away
at some level it's already here with the
smart watches and rings now the other
story I'd like to tell you about is some
of our recent work to analyze autism and
so this is a very important disease I
think you may know as many as 1 in 68
children are born each year with autism
and it's an area that people are trying
to study at incredible detail but it's
very hard to get your hands around it
one aspect of autism there is a genetic
component there's probably a strong
environmental component as well and
genetically the way people have been
going at this they initially did this
with something called G Watson and
genotyping arrays and these dayz do it
by sequencing and you
coach most people do this will go in and
they'll sequence lots of people either
spontaneous cases or familial cases
they're going in sequence the the cases
meaning the autistic kids and compare
that to controls and they'll do this for
thousands of people now they try and
find the rare variants that might be
associated with the disease and then
deduce biological pathways and in my
opinion for the most part this has been
a pretty dismal process that is to say
if the sequence many many people half
the studies have not found anything
significant the other half do find
variants are not very common and the
most people really learned is that
synaptic genes are important for autism
and it's been a very unclear picture so
Jing Jing Li in my lab actually decided
to take a different approach he wanted
to flip this whole thing on its head
which is rather than just trying
sequence deeply and deeply and deeply
and try and find rare variants of low
effect that might be involved in disease
so let's let's turn this whole thing on
its head can we look at the way things
are naturally organized and then from
the sequencing study see what might map
on to biological processes that might be
important for the disease so
specifically oh if you're outside what
people are doing nails or even
sequencing more and more and more to try
and learn less and less and less if you
ask me so it's like squeezing water out
of a rock actually and in fact there
this is becoming very common is to say
if you sequence a thousand people you
don't learn anything people now seek
went six thousand I just heard someone
give a talk on this will sequence 6,000
cases and then they'll find five genes a
very long x and now they're talking
about sequencing 30,000 people to find
even you know a few more genes of even
lower effect and it really is a very
difficult process so the approach we
wanted to do is the one I just mentioned
here it's actually let's see how things
are naturally organized and then see
where these mutations might lie on the
natural organization of proteins and
then from that proteins we might
identify we can try to characterize them
and see what kinds of processes are
involved in and I hope this will become
clear in just a minute so just a flick
playing this in a little more detail you
can look at proteins organization at
many different levels just like you can
look at the way people are organized on
the planet so we have the world
population as you know and we're
organizing the countries and then in
countries are low they're organized
people are organized into States or
provinces and then below that I have the
city of San Francisco which is
organizing the neighborhoods and below
that you can see people are organized
into families well proteins have that
same kind of organization so the whole
set of proteins is your protium you can
actually order NYSE's into processes or
groups of proteins that like to work
together shown in the middle and at the
bottom of the biochemical complexes
things like ribosomes or proteasomes or
a transcription machinery that actually
has very specific functions for carrying
out things those are like families if
you will and Ben and within those are
the individual proteins and so what
jinjing did was he decided to organize
pro look at proteins organized and sort
of that middle layer and so he took an
unbiased protein interaction network
where other groups mostly the toronto
group have actually looked at various
proteins that associate with one another
doing something called pulldown
experiments in jingjiang using borrowing
some organizational information for
other fields organize the components not
again at the very detailed level the
complex level we have done that too but
you looked at at this higher level where
there's about a hundred proteins per
module if you were a group of proteins
that like to work together so it's a set
of proteins that generally like to
associate with one another and work
together in the same processes and then
he said let's take all these autism
tight jeans and see where they map onto
the protein interaction network and so
we started out with a set of genes that
most people would say are involved in
autism they're called the Safari genes
their 383 of them and you map them onto
these modules and two of the modules
were highly enriched for these kinds of
jeans these autism genes one of them
there is module 13 it's very frequently
mutated and these are sorry it's very
frequent
these safari genes as they're called and
it turns out it's also frequently
mutated so I'll show you in a minute and
then there's another one that we didn't
characterize quite as much it's evolved
in chromatin remodeling so we actually
wanted to see further whether this MA
this might really be affected by autism
so we took all the sequencing studies
out there all the genomic studies out
there there eight of them and in every
single case the mutations the affected
genes were much much higher on this
module 13 that we identified then in
controls and and it was quite striking
that every single time this happened
i've just shown for on this slide but
there's four other studies as well these
aren't necessarily the best of the worst
scores the bottom line is they're higher
the genes in this module much much more
frequently mutated than other genes so
there's something special about that
even took this one step further where we
went out in sequence you the study
should have worked at all if you would
think about the current field but he
went out in sequence 25 of our own
autism patients that have characterized
as autistic along with some sequencing
controls and once you know even this set
of 25 patients they're highly enriched
for mutations in the same module so that
tells you this is really something
involved in autism he then wanted to
characterize the module where is it
express on all the sort of good stuff
where well what can we learn about this
module what will tell us about autism
and what he did was he actually took the
set of 119 jeans it is in this module 13
and he asked where they're expressed on
the in the brain and the Allen brain
atlas has done a remarkable job about
looking for expression of thousands of
genes throughout 295 regions of the
brain and once you know one group of
genes the group to actually maps sort of
the way we would expect it's mostly
express in neurons and actually Bigfoot
us throughout the brain and this have
been known already most people are
studying deep cortical neurons and for
the role in autism and that's what the
way or think he goes and that kind of
matches a set of genes but the other
part was a surprise the top set of genes
up there called group 1 genes is 56
teams those are predominantly expressed
in the corpus callosum not
i express their but quite enriched and
this was a surprise as everybody's been
studying cortical neurons and suddenly
we found this other part of the brain
which is involved in communication
across your hemispheres is actually
likely to be heavily mutated an autism
patients so this is again a very big
surprise to see this and it turns out
this set of cells there are mostly
non-neuronal cells in fact I won't have
time to show you this but they're
primarily oligodendrocytes and again
because of running a little late i'll
won't spend much time on this but we can
actually verify all this information
using RNA seek experiments that we
perform we can show that the group one
genes really are mostly express in the
corpus callosum and the others are
expressed in other parts of the brain
and we can do this across several
different individuals and show that get
the same result each time again the one
set of genes love to be expressed in the
corpus callosum the other setting is
expressed in neurons and and somehow
together they're involved in autism and
this just shows we can actually get
mouse homologs for these same genes look
at where they're expressed based on
published information and again the
group one genes are primarily expressed
in the oligodendrocytes and the other
genes are primarily expressing group two
ones in the neurons so one of the most
interesting things is we were able to
get six match patients and controls and
we can ask are these genes how are these
genes express and the patients versus
controls the much our amazement it turns
out the this module is set 119 genes
business regulated and the patients
relative to the controls so the point
out of all this is that here's a set of
genes a module that somehow involved in
autism and tend to be heavily mutated it
tends to be it's expressed and some
parts of the brain we didn't realize
before so it actually implicates this
whole part of the new part of the brain
in autism well there's some
morphological data to support what I
just said and also a whole new set of
cell types so the point out of all this
is that by taking new approaches and by
bringing other kinds of information we
can learn a lot
about a disease it's been very well
studied and learn new things that no one
has actually ever been able to see
before so to wrap all this up personal
genome sequencing is here all of you do
have the option of getting your genome
sequence at some point in your lifetime
and it's something you may think about
and we do believe it can be used to
predict disease risk and help manage
health I do think these multi amex
approaches are valuable not only for
research studies like the one I
described for making trying to see how
pathways change in diseases and also try
and understand things like autism but i
also think they're going to be very
valuable for actually directly managing
your health I also think two other very
important lessons out of all this are
that longitudinal profiles are
incredibly valuable and these days most
people do science by setting cases and
controls but if you think about
understanding longitudinal profiles are
much better you want to see how people
change over time when they get sick and
when they're healthy and so I will argue
at the end of the day you really want to
understand your disease state relative
to your healthy state not your disease
state relative to everybody else is
healthy safe because that's not too
valuable so I would argue you should get
one of these omics profiles now while
you're healthy before you have disease
you can understand what happened during
that time and lastly I will argue the
health profession isn't at all prepared
for genomics and this whole rebel
revolutions going on and I think that
you as a as a person will really have to
take responsibility for your own health
because 15 minutes in the doctor's
office just isn't kind of cut it for
properly managing your health these are
the people my lab that did the work it
was set up by riri-chan in George miyase
initially now when you shall Brian
pining and many others have been
extremely helpful in launching this as
part of the human microbiome project and
I specifically want to mention Tracy
McLaughlin and George Weinstock and his
panel of the lab and the autism work was
won by done by Jing Jing Li Yakima Meyer
and Alex urban and lastly if you're at
all interested in this kind of research
I talked about or just this field in
general we've recently launched a new
certificate program here at Stanford
that all of you are welcome to take it's
a it's
somewhat intensive online core class but
it covers a lot of topics I just
mentioned genetics genomics personalized
medicine cancer genomics things like
that so feel free to visit us online and
learn more about this whole topic so
happy to take questions if any of come
in those a very informative presentation
thank you before we start on the
question and answer session I'd like to
remind our audience how to submit
questions you can do that by typing them
in the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can and the first question could you
comment on rheumatoid arthritis
population variations well that's not an
area we've studied although interested
well we have one small study going on
there I mean rheumatoid arthritis
obviously is an autoimmune disease and
there have been some antigens associated
with it but even that does vary quite a
bit both in severity and the types of
antigens people have and I would say
it's certainly not fully known how this
whole thing works so believe it or not
we're actually studying it in a Native
American population with the goal of
trying to learn more about this so
that's all I can say i'm not an expert
in rheumatoid arthritis de smita cure or
obamacare pay for the sequencing well
this is a great question so the answer
right now is almost no one pays for the
sequencing unless these days you can get
sequencing done for cancer patients if
it can be justified and also for many of
the childhood diseases i mentioned
earlier so this is very interesting
point abhi cuz basically right now we
actually sequence people only when
they're sick not when they're healthy
and I would argue that you an insurance
company should actually be paying for us
to get our genome sequence because we'll
better manage your health and in the
long run it will save us save money but
the our whole system is broken it really
doesn't work that way and if you think
about it the socialized medicine
countries will have a huge head start
us for this because basically right now
there's no impetus for a provider to be
able to want to sequence you if it's
going to cost fifteen thousand dollars
because in the US people change their
their employer and also their health
plan quite frequently so nobody wants to
lay out all the cash if you're going to
wind up changing your job and go to a
different provider although in the long
run it would be better if everybody did
but I would argue they should be but in
the socialized medicine country in fact
they're now talking out about sequencing
a hundred thousand people in the UK and
now either even talking about sequencing
all of the people in Estonia of all
places the whole population to be able
to better manage their health so you
socialized medicine countries they have
have an edge on us I don't know how this
will play the Obamacare anything like
that but I do think we need a mechanism
to be able to incentivize people to do
this because I actually do think they
will manage their health better so maybe
they will get some water out of Estonia
haha what are the more expensive
components of the $15,000 analysis
process that's a great question the it's
really due to the fact that there's a
lot of manual curation involved so we'll
sequence a genome and call the variants
that really is about fourteen hundred
dollars maybe fifteen hundred dollars
and if you add to it in a certified lab
it costs more because they're more
controls but it's the only two thousand
dollars but once those variants come
back we can run them through pipelines
and caught ematic pipelines and call
quite a bit but at the end of the day
someone looks up all the variants and
why do they do that well turns out the
public databases are wrong about nine
percent of the time that is to say
people put the wrong information in and
so something that right now has to
manually curate and look up every one of
these variants you don't want to tell
somebody they're at risk for x and
realize that whole thing was a mistake
because somebody had entered the
information wrong in a database so
somebody really has to go back and read
the paper and see what the information
was before they tell you anything and
that's why it costs so much it literally
takes about an hour per change that we
look up and there's typically about 70
to 100 changes in a person we think are
worth looking
app so it's a very expensive and
laborious process why are environmental
influences such as food exercise toxins
etc important in human health well yeah
why are they well I guess because the
DNA only does so much I mean I obviously
logically you're the food you eat really
determines the metabolite you have in
your body which determines how you will
essentially behave in such and also
affects all the vitamins you have and
things like this my own view is that the
food you eat is very very tightly tied
to your microbiome and also very very
tightly tied to your metabolomic lect
your energy state and what we don't
understand is how they affect you
epigenetic alee like how will that lead
to either DNA methylation or chromatin
changes so that your gene expression
patterns are changed and that that part
is still very unknown it's a great
question though here's another one how
many fourteen hundred dollar acids did
you need to do on yourself to confirm
what your grandmother probably told you
haha that's a great question well the
fourteen hundred dollars is a genome
sequence and I hate to say it but we
actually sequenced my genome back when
it was twenty-five thousand dollars so
it costs even more and we we did that
she booked my blood and my spit because
we're trying to see changes so it was
very expensive in the end though it
turns out what my grandmother didn't
tell me was that as a risk for type 2
diabetes so it is true that my
grandmother told me a lot that I did
learn from my genome sequence but it's
also true that there were things my
grandmother didn't tell me it didn't
know and I think the other thing that's
going to be the power out of this is the
frequency with which these measurements
come up that is to say I think you're
going to see these changes appear now
more real-time so if you think about
most healthy people go to the doctor
every two to three years and or when
they get very ill and that's just too
infrequent and it's also too late why
time somebody has symptoms and you
discover something is wrong it's very
hard to reverse
process whether it's cancer whether it's
diabetes if once the symptoms appear
you're in a not great state so the goal
is really to catch and predict things
ahead of time now it could be the hidden
part of that messages eat better
exercise more and that one I can't argue
that that is a good thing to do
routinely anyway but I actually think it
does drive at home when you see these
things earlier if you like when I saw my
glucose shooting through the roof
obviously I had to act have you observed
increased glucose levels correlated with
emotional stress yeah we haven't really
pin that down but the plan is to pin
that down better and I think with these
automatic sensors I have on me we will
be looking at that more carefully it's a
great question my guests will be yes but
we haven't we haven't rigorously pin
that down it's being evaluated now
what's your best guesstimate as to when
the precision medicine approach will be
taught and and used commercially yeah
that's a great question too i would say
it will roll out in phases so to speak
that and one example right now is cancer
that is to say i think people are and
how sequencing people's genome or parts
of their genome and base months late
once they've cancer and then actually
trying to target drugs for that so
that's a no brainer where it's rolling
out I think the other area is in these
childhood diseases again and then I
think as people get more and more
comfortable with this then it will
become much more frequent but right now
it always comes down to who pays who
would pay you to get who would pay
fifteen thousand dollars or twenty
thousand dollars to get your genome
sequence when they can't they have to
show insurance companies want to see
there's direct benefit usually they have
to see that and see a proven before
they'll pay for it and that's hard to do
especially in a prospective situation
when somebody doesn't have the Ziva
that's the resistance but it'll come I
think again and it won't necessarily be
fair that is people who can afford will
probably do it out of the realm pocket
and that's how it'll probably roll out
and then i'll show you Tilly then people
what
lysis really is a good thing and they'll
expand it out further that would be
that's my guess on how this whole thing
I'll roll out somebody's got a follow-on
question very germane do you think the
day will come when you're a set of
experiments will be reduced to a $25
essay so everyone can afford the best
care and you can substitute another
dollar figure 4 25 that's still
reasonable labrador 3 III really do I
think these I think we don't know
obviously what we're doing now is a
research project with the billions of
measurements our goal is to distill this
to a few hundred or a few thousand
things we measure rather than billions
that will be critical and capture a lot
of the same information and I think that
could get set up as automatic sensors
and we become very very inexpensive so I
think the answer to that is yes it would
be a long ways off for twenty-five
dollars as you point out that maybe for
a few hundred dollars and have it every
at least every three months or maybe
even again continuously in some cases I
don't think those that will come it's
not going to be 50 years from now I
think it'll be it's hard to say these
things are hard to predict but i'll bet
within 5 to 15 years we'll see some form
of us what are the things in the
environment that are reflected in the
methylated janome and is there any way
to slow it down or speed it up yeah I
wish I knew and certainly that's
something I'd like to work on and better
get working on it sooner I'm not getting
any younger so we don't we don't know as
the answer to that and I think we that
that whole part is very mysterious but
things that we do now and at least cross
generations as nutrition is important to
people who have gone through starvation
phases their their their their their
kids and grandkids will actually be
affected by that so it passes on to
several generation and there's some very
interesting studies about conception of
kids in Gambia kids that are conceived
in the dry period when food is more
abundant actually are bigger than kids
that are conceived in the wet period
when food is more scarce and so and
bigger and healthier i should say
and so there is a correlation that's at
least several genes and how that exactly
translate in the health we do we don't
know but I think at the end of the day
we will see this and there's a very
interesting study by the way out by
Scandinavian group where they had a
group of people that exercise to one leg
on a bicycle so they had one leg its
control the other one they exercised I
think it was four days a week for
several months and then they looked at
the methylation pattern in the muscle of
the exercise lag versus the other and
their methylation patterns had changed
so in fact that tells you exercise does
directly affect your DNA and how that
will lead to longevity or anything like
that I don't know but it's a very
fascinating study I'll say I've got a
long commute to work I wonder if my
accelerator pedal leg is getting
differentially methylated probably but I
think you'd have a lot more effect if
you use the bicycle than your
accelerator like their improves haha
sure oh but these are great questions by
the way and and if you think about just
think about a viral infection one could
ask why is it in my case for the RSV
infection that you know the virus came
and went literally in days but my sugar
was up for eight months write a long
time and only went down we think after I
intervened so there clearly is some big
epi affect whether it's epigenetic
whether it's epidemic or something there
is some lasting effect out of this and
so these are the basic questions no
one's really ever investigated and I
think they're I think they are a
solvable omics is still not affordable
for developing countries but what do you
suggest research researchers should be
doing in this respect yeah well I guess
to two answers that number one is we
have to make sure we include diverse
populations in our studies which we're
trying to do so that right now you may
know that most studies that are done
especially genetic studies are done on
Europeans and there now is a bigger push
track to include other populations
Asians african-americans
Africans and even Native Americans so
there people are trying to branch out to
be more inclusive and so that's one
thing that needs to be done as far as
you know this really is a research study
it's no one's going to really learn
something there are a lot of logistics
associated with its cost millions is set
up all the equipment for this it's not a
trivial study so i think the early
version will just be done in a limited
places where the resources do exist and
then as we have a better idea what to
look at how often a sample this sort of
thing i think a version of this can move
out to other places where it's you know
the infrastructure is not as good and i
think they're going to be very very
important studies to do so we can make
sure we include all populations I think
some fundamental parameters in fact
we're running studies like this where
we're running people through diet
perturbations changing people's diet and
see what effect it has on their omics
profile I think the information from
that will also be pertinent worldwide as
well what happens when you eat that Big
Mac what does that do to your omics
profile in your DNA methyl um that sort
of thing and these are the kinds of
questions we would like to answer and
again I think that could have huge
impact what genes seem to be involved in
the insulin resistant versus insulin
sensitive diabetic population that's
another great Kyle great questions I'm
one thing we have noticed is the there's
these set of genes called Modi genes
that are involved in insulin both
production or in insulin sensitivity
they somehow seem to be involved and
that their expression does seem to be
different that's one of the things we've
noticed other things that are different
the inflammatory response seems to be
different between insulin sensitive in
insulin-resistant folks so I think
there's something there and also some of
their metabolic effects like oxidative
phosphorylation and things like that
seem to be different so we could we've
just started identifying these things
now how to intervene and change that as
something we'd like to do as a next step
but right now
we're just really trying to learn the
differences and then the next step is
essay will be intervention can we study
the onset of neurodegenerative
degenerative disorders with this
technology I'd like to do that you know
a lot of them that you'd like to study
would be well especially things like
autism well that's not so
neurodegenerative I guess but you you
would like to study them in kids and
follow them through the
neurodegenerative once they're often
very slow but there but they could be
for example Parkinson's Alzheimer's I
think these would be really really
valuable to study and and and see the
other thing I would add is that a lot of
these diseases they're probably not one
disease diabetes schizophrenia and some
of the neurodegenerative diseases
they're really probably multiple
diseases all lumped together into one
and i think the omics profiling would be
very very valuable for trying to
stratify just how many diseases are
there and they would also be incredibly
valuable for trying to treat diseases we
can see how people respond when you give
them a certain treatment if you treat
them with a drug we can see what's
happening is there is there um xpro file
looking more like a healthy person or
more like a disease or the disease state
still remaining we've got time for one
last question what percentage of
metabolites is mass spectrometry
detecting can they all be integrated
into pathways that's a great question
the answer is we don't know we don't
even know how many human metabolites
there are how many we make how many we
bring from our food things like that so
the human metabolism has still got a
long ways to go and so and we do see and
even when we detect them we detect them
as peaks in a mass back and we don't
know what most of those Peaks are so a
we don't know how many metabolites are
there be when we see things that we see
we don't know exactly what they are so
it's hard to important to pathways so
the net result out of all this is would
there's just a lot more basic work to be
done here
to just catalog it under seeing where
they fit in the pathways and I think a
lot of them won't even go into single
pathways they'll be they'll be
substrates and products of pathways but
to regulate many other things one
example is we found that at least in
yeast and we think the same is true for
humans ergosterol and humans called
cholesterol it's actually probably
involved and not just as a structural
protein but it probably regulates lots
of other proteins as well so I think
there's going to be lots of unknown
functions and metabolites and those are
things we need to figure out as well so
lots more to do thank you all for
attending I would also like to thank our
sponsor Stanford University for making
today's educational webcast possible
this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through November 14th
you'll receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for display for a replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's in that event thanks and goodbye